Ben Mezrich of course you guys know him
he's the author of the books that they
turn into the Facebook movie he's the
author of the book that they turned into
21 does that like does that ever argue
that the people that are like yeah
you're famous because you really go to
that movie and like you just read the
book I know I get it and the social
network was a really good movie and 21
was a lot of fun so I luckily mm at
least associated with goodness you don't
have a lot of control over that but I
like III see the book in the movie is
one in the same at this point you do so
you do feel like a sense of attachment
yeah I mean I actually sell the movie
projects usually before I write the book
so I write a proposal I sell it as a
movie and then I sell it as a book and
is that because you have this reputation
of this is what he writes I mean that's
the white why I can do that I mean why
it works out I think I've always wanted
to write books that were like movies or
some cinematic writer and my goal is
that you read the book and are seeing it
like you're seeing a movie so definitely
yeah I mean some critics don't like that
and but I've always seen them as one in
the same do you when you watch it like
I'm sure you watch the movies there me
yeah do when you watch them do you see
like oh yeah that's like like cuz when I
read a book and then watch the movie I
can always see like especially it hit me
hard
I think this why didn't like the Steve
Jobs movie right because I was so
invested in that book and I love Steve
Jobs so much that I saw the danny boyle
movie and it was like i got what he was
doing and a lot of people really liked
it but I saw all these little parts of
the book and the book was so big that he
was felt like he was just trying to get
them all in all right all in and it was
a guy it's not the story do you see your
story in the movie I mean you know so i
I've been lucky I mean it's really only
been two movies so far but I do you know
when I'm writing the book I'm not
picturing specific actors or I'm not
specific but I am picturing the scenes
as they come about and it is cool when
you watch the movie and you see it seen
exactly how you kind of wrote it other
times you see scenes that you didn't
write it but in general I've liked every
the aspects of it I mean the social
network was great you Fincher you a
Sorkin and even rent Reznor doing the
resident doing amusing you won the Oscar
for it at the Eisenberg was great
so cool so hopefully Willy will be
saying the same but yeah you know you
never know
so Willy is a it's great and it already
isn't it it's it's amazing when you can
put out a book right and on the cover
you can write soon to be a motion
picture on yeah like most of the time
that's in the reprint right hey and they
change the cover so it's the movie
poster and the whole deal like that's
not you know it's crazy it's a crazy
situation but Willy is going to be a
movie
Marty Bowen who did Twilight and Maze
Runner is making the movie of 20 Century
Fox and hopefully we'll be shooting by
the winter so Willy is a it's my first
book that's sort of moving that quickly
in terms of the Hollywood side yeah
because you vet it you've got a couple
books so they think what was the book
the last time we spoke about 37th
parallel and we are making that movie as
well right okay so remember Torrey yes
and that's being made by new line that's
going to be really cool too but yeah
this is a it's all kind of you know
let's know volleying on through each
other which is really cool you end up
with like six Ben Mezrich movie it's one
after the other after the other one all
in the same week so wooly is super super
interesting it's it's about scientists
that we're trying to bring this woolly
mammoth species back right and and the
reason they were trying to bring it back
was because it would help with the
climate right yeah this is a true story
right the true story right now yes
that's key right so Willy is the true
story of a team of scientists at Harvard
who are bringing back the woolly mammoth
so the woolly mammoth died out you know
most of them 12,000 years ago a small
group of woolly mammoths walked across
an ice bridge to an island called
wrangle island in the Arctic Circle and
it's again is true like and they lived
another eight thousand years so woolly
mammoth died out three thousand years
ago the last one which is a cool thought
in itself that woolly mammoths were
around when people were building
pyramids right because you think you
think they're ancient species yeah
they're not like dinosaur was this
island right or there was the island of
woolly mammoths right amazing and so now
by the way that is specific movie month
oh yeah that we you land on Island and
it's it's the king Long Island or
Godzilla mammoth but now this group of
scientists have taken the DNA out of
these frozen mammoths that are coming up
out of the ice they've sequenced the DNA
and they are implanting gee
jeans from wooly mammoths into the
embryos of an Asian elephant so an Asian
elephant will give birth to a wooly
mammoth
which is wild it's very drastic park but
real and then the reason they're doing
this is essentially to save the world
this is where it gets kind of crazy from
but so the entire ring of the world the
tundra across Russia across the top of
Canada is this giant permafrost you know
vast region it takes up a large amount
of our geography and the permafrost
which is always frozen ground
is on the verge of melting I know people
discuss whether or not this is real
enough but this is real the permafrost
contains within it more carbonate and
carbon dioxide than if we burned all the
forests on earth three times Wow ticking
time-bomb
the per if the permafrost actually does
melt yeah it's going to release ton the
carbon dioxide and it's kind of like
game over that's the end of the plan
well that's that's the idea is it
accelerates everything Wow well it turns
out these Russian scientists the Z moths
it's a father-and-son team since the 80s
have been running this crazy experiment
where they've roped off a large section
of the tundra and they repopulated it
with giant herbivores they're using
reindeer and bison they actually got a
world war two era
tank which they drive up and down the
permafrost to mimic a mammoth and what
they discovered is that woolly mammoths
actually kept it cold and they've kept
their area of the tundra 15 degrees
colder than the rest of the tundra so
the plan is if you can put a herd of
woolly mammoths back into the tundra
wanting to lower the temperature of the
permafrost for as much as a hundred
years that's crazy
it's crazy it's an outsider I wouldn't
melt right because the bam--it's would
come and make it cool that's right and
so it's this kind of cool project in
that you know everyone's like oh we got
a how do we save the environment we got
a recycle or we get and now these are
all things you have to do I got to stop
driving or I gotta but if we let these
scientists make woolly mammoths we don't
have to do anything right and the woolly
mammoths will do the words and hairspray
all right right the woolly mammoth do
the natural work and this is an
interesting situation so I don't know I
the project their goal is to make 80,000
woolly mammoths an entire herd how
so so far in existence right now yes
there are three genes there's no mammoth
right so 0 right 0 right now okay
there's a scene in the book where they
ask one of the scientists where you're
william emma is going to live and he
says in a petri dish the first ones are
three living prehistoric mammoth genes
are now alive in Asian elephant cells in
Boston which is the start which is a
cool thought there's prehistoric in
bothy na now alive in Boston the first
woolly mammoth could be born about three
years from today okay and where what is
a centum right to the tundra no well you
got to raise them to think about
elephants elephants are raised by their
parents
elephants are like kind of like people
and that they're very smart they have
family relationships they even mourn
their dead elephants if a baby elephant
dies the parent elephants will come back
to that spot and I'm warned it's kind of
sad and cool so if you have a baby
woolly mammoth you have to have Asian
elephants raise it the goal is to make a
bunch of and that's the thing everybody
wants to have woolly mammoths but they
don't have Asian elephants right well
what are you get it we got a hope to
help the Asian elephants - so the woolly
mammoth team got their elephants from
Ringling Brothers so Ringling Brothers
you know it's going out of business yes
and they're giving their elephants to
the to the team that's making woolly
mammoths why do they have to be Asian
elephants so Asian elephants are very
close to woolly mammoths they're about
99.9% the same as a woolly mammoth
woolly mammoths are bigger and have the
red hair and the giant tusks of course
but other than that they're very similar
animals and also Asian elephants are
even though they're rare they're they're
good they're kind they're nice they're
curious as opposed African elephants are
actually violent and aggressive so
originally they tried to use African
elephants and realize quickly would be a
bad idea to make Giant African elephants
so they're working with Asian elephants
even though they're endangered they're
trying to avoid a planet of the a wild I
want it to be Jurassic Park they're not
making music worse where the elephants
go crazy and eat everybody will
amendments are good creatures they're
not we killed them we ate them not the
other way around
so do you then have the Asian elephants
raised the mammoths in their own
environment there's a lot of ideas being
put forth one of the goals of the team
is to actually find a way to do it
without having the Asian elephant give
birth so there are
working on a synthetic womb so they're
actually going to grow the elephants in
a lab the woolly mammoths in a lab
without having to have them be born from
an Asian elephant but once they're born
you will need to put them in an
environment with parents and once
they're raised up to a certain age then
you're going to release them into the
wild right now do we have an ending to a
movie here because it's yeah as an
ongoing the book Willy if you if you
read it it's it's very Ocean's eleven II
because it's about this group of
scientists most of them are very young
so there's George church is this genius
Einstein of our era
one of them's British one of them does
backflip they're all you know anything
exactly very much like that and they
have to sort of figure out how to do
this and then they have to go up to the
Arctic to get the materials to do it and
there's this whole theme with tusks
hunters there are tribes in the accout
Siberia that live on woolly mammoth
tusks a woolly mammoth tusk is worth a
quarter million dollars and they're
coming up out of the ice and people are
going out to harvest them which
interesting it's the same people who ate
them out of existence are now going to
find their tusks so these tribes have
been around for thousands of years you
put away you get your first woolly
mammoth back and then it gets killed for
it to us and you're like oh the goal
will be to rope it off and not let
people go hunt them as they exist you
know people will want to obviously but
the goal is to sort of keep them alive
long enough to pick and survive why do
the tribes want mammoth touches if it's
oh it's the jewelry you said - ivory in
China ivory is huge morenas and even in
America people love ivory and elephant
ivory is illegal because it's an
endangered species but mammoth ivory is
perfectly legal because it's get ready
like I don't send bodies right so there
and as the the Arctic is warming more
and more of the tusks are coming up and
people are going up there to get these
tusks and they're actually finding fully
preserved woolly mammoths Wow you know
frozen to the point where you can
actually see what looks like red blood
in them a Russian team found the woolly
mammoth and cut it open and actually
something liquid came out of it that
which is a wild thought you know it's
been thousands of years in the ice so
when you start a project right yeah and
if I assume the first step of starting
the project is to become an expert on
the thing that as much as I can yeah
yeah and it's a lime you get read a book
about it that's right that's significant
do
you end up maintaining expertise from
project to project or do you lose
everything in my brain did you know is
overwhelmed I try to sort of stay with
the knowledge you know some level of
knowledge goes away but in terms of like
the woolly mammoth I became an expert as
much as I could I'm not a scientist and
DNA is hard for me as it is for most
people to understand soj jury
it's very right it's very difficult and
I had to relearn stuff that I'd never
really knew from sight I've never looked
through a microscope and actually seen
anything I got really bad I don't know
what look I know yeah but but the story
of the woolly mammoth I think is so
dramatic that I was able to sort of
figure it out but yeah I think I stay an
expert in some of the topic do you like
so Facebook version yeah I know
everything about basically yeah I know
yeah I'm color you like how do I change
my brush
I do do talk sometimes people will ask
questions I like that I don't know those
answers but you do you follow the story
meaning it's like you know you you told
the story is kind of the the rise of
Facebook do you follow some fairness and
what Zuckerberg do I do whatever
happened well people want to ask me
about Zuckerberg all the time so I have
to kind of stalk Zuckerberg a little bit
know what's going on with him I think
he's going to run for president actually
you do I do
so I've sort of been following everyone
not bed for I think the Boston Globe
about him running for president he's
going to run for president I think it's
part of what he wants out of the world I
mean see his goal with Facebook was to
change the world the Greece's revolution
so people like him could do well
socially so he created this online world
where people like Mark Zuckerberg could
have lots of friends and right and I
think his next goal is that we're all in
Facebook and then he becomes president
to make our world better I think he
truly is believes he's making the world
better with each thing he does and I
think he thinks a world where there's no
privacy where we share everything where
it's all interconnected is the world we
should be striving towards what do you
think and maybe advise to Facebook in my
mind I see Facebook Amazon and Google as
the three companies right now they're
kind of vying for global domination and
I mean I don't mean like that's just the
biggest company in the world I mean they
control everything but I have all the
information they have all the
and television is Facebook Amazon or
Google everything where we get our food
from right where we store everything all
of our I mean and you're absolutely
right and they're battling it out and
they are really battling to who gets to
AI first right you know is they're all
three working on AI every minute of
every day like it is it VR first I mean
they're all trying to do that it's
interesting I would have said normally
Facebook I think Facebook's going to
dominate the world because they they
dominate what we do all day long
Amazon is dominating the physical world
you know what we buy and how we buy
things and now with Whole Foods and
whatever how we eat everything like that
will eventually be under Amazon's
control but Facebook is going to get our
minds they're in our heads every minute
of the day and you know the Instagram
Facebook I think Facebook has a real
head start on that I do think I think
that and it'll be something as simple as
one day in the not so distant future I
think that Facebook is going to get
exclusive rights to the Super Bowl or
something is an interesting idea once
that happens you've got connectivity on
an even bigger level and people are now
used to it and it just becomes more and
more I think that I mean I really
intriguing and interesting you know I
Amazon is going to be doing football now
right I do think that that's they have
the money and that's where it kind of
like in Hollywood for instance when you
take a book like Willie out to sell it
as a movie you've got Netflix you've got
Amazon these people are out bidding
studios right on so it's it's it's
definitely moving the direction I put on
you know jet avid I was just in here and
I put on his movie the big sick which
comes out in theaters today right and I
turn it on and I was shocked because
Amazon Studios absolutely I know it's
right here movies I mean and you know a
potala understands that that's where the
answer is you know and Netflix and
Amazon er are really moving forward now
i'm with studio I ever this is being
made by Fox I'm right my movie but I
understand about of money they're doing
fine they're doing fine be alright but
it is you know the Facebook future is
where we're all heading and I don't
think you can do much about that
DJI is as scary as I do I think it's I'm
getting the end of AI could be very
scary it all depends on who gets where
first and for what reason I think once
AI kind of escapes the petri dish as it
were is it
it's an interesting and scary thing I
think what's going on in synthetic
biology which is what will it's about is
even scarier people don't see it and
they everyone talks about AI in this set
but what is going on in labs right now
is is incredibly terrifying and exciting
I was thinking about that as I was going
through the book like the savior of this
story is that they want to they want to
do good things righted things I guess
otherwise it's just playing God and
right it creates B we're at a point
right now where a couple of smart kids
in a garage can make a virus can make
can change someone's biology it's called
bio hacking but you essentially could
get a flu virus in your garage and make
it more you know deadly and that's not
hard to do and when you start thinking
about that it gets very scary I mean
they're creating a woolly mammoth
they're not they're not cloning it
they're actually making the DNA we're at
the point in life right now where you're
not reading DNA you're writing DNA I
mean yet effective a so you can make
anything biologically and that that is a
big change in our future at the same
time good things are going to happen
we're going to live 150 to 200 years in
the next generation because of what's
going on in this lab they actually
believe our children will live 150 years
and our children's children may not die
so using the kids that are born in I
have a four months yes we'll live 150 to
180 years that's incredibly cuz of
what's going on in the book will you
know because of what's going on in
genetics because the ability for
instance one of the experiments they
talked about in the book and that's in
their lab there's a certain type of rat
called the naked mole rat which lives 30
years while other rats only live three
years and the question is why does that
rat live ten times as long as all other
rats when they're almost the same and it
turns out there's something in their
genetics that protects their cells as
they as they as they mutate so it turns
out if you can take that gene and put it
into people people's lifespans are
accelerated and this is very we're on
the cutting edge of this so within the
next decade there's going to be these
advancements that are going to allow our
kids to live a hundred fifty years